the experience of making Winter Soldier
was fantastic and we didn't feel like
the story was finished that we were
telling in their film so you know for us
it was a no-brainer we wanted to keep
going with it I could do this all day
the Russo brothers are back in their
Marvel director's chairs for Captain
America Civil War something went punch
you in your perfect teeth part of
Captain America's superpower is that
he's such a sort of strong ethical
centered moral character it's hard to
deal with a character like that because
you know we like vulnerabilities and our
characters in our story telling but
that's one thing was most excited about
in this movie is I think we finally push
him to a place that's gonna surprise
people and places never been before and
it's but it's a very human place to suit
up you can look forward to plenty of new
team members hey spider-man everyone but
here's why we're not calling Civil War
Avengers 2.5 so everything's first half
Captain America's point of view in the
phone that's a you know the main story
is X credibly personal to him as a
character movie starts with in the movie
ends with him so you know some people
think it gets overly complicated when
you bring another characters for those
characters are there to service the main
storyline of the main storylines